like thousands of gambians will now
leave us why
abdullah money went home to make sure he
would be registered to vote
he didn't think he'd have to fly back to
the gambia to make that happen
we were expecting to register as the
dashboard to
stay abroad where we live but
unfortunately
the last minute they changed everything
that
we can't register you know outside the
country
so we have the only option we have is to
come back home gambians living abroad
like abdullahi send money home regularly
to support families and to invest in
their country
those remittances amount to a fifth of
the gambia's gdp
many feel they have a right to vote
wherever
they now live but the election
commission says that's a decision for
parliament
and the laws are currently not in place
it's our intention to go to eastern
foreign what the law has to be amended
so that they will be allowed to vote to
each other and vote
and also to represent the parliament
which means hundreds of gambians have
made what can be a
very expensive trip home to get their
voters cards
after 44 days of this registration
exercise it looks like the target for
new registrations
may have been met the election
commission says it wants to raise voter
registration to one million names
it's targeting tens of thousands of
gambians reluctant to vote under the
previous administration
this is the first major overhaul of
that list since yayami left power in
2017.
young gambians who are distrustful of
the government and officials
have turned up in numbers xenapsani was
underage when the last voter's list was
updated
now she's qualified to vote
i am happy to register to vote for the
first time because i want to see my
generation transformed
with a newfound freedom of choice and
expression many gambians say they want
to take charge of their lives
they want change in accountability
something unheard of
when yaya jamie was in power for 22
years until 2017.
ahmed ruiz al jazeera bonjour